kind of a big deal I'm saying I'm trying
to stay chill but I'm very happy about
this development I love it I hope you
get a chance to maybe picture on
something and the two of you team up
star and something together I mean she
is a mogul so I feel like you know she
she might but also it's okay if we just
meet sure for sure fall in love and go
on road trips anyway weekend we can
Daydream all day long congratulations on
this well-deserved honor you are in what
I like to lovingly call an innocence you
are I want to get this right you have
seven projects coming up on your IMDb
everything it's true it's true
everything you wear turns into a viral
moment you just celebrated 10 years of
marriage how does this season of Life
stack up against the rest
oh what a lovely question thank you so
much
um I'm I'm so lucky in that my life has
always been very very full and fortunate
um but I'm in a place where I'm able to
enjoy it differently
um you know I used to come through these
things and I would truly like tremble I
would be so anxious I really would and I
would kind of I know I know it because
it is a little sad that that I was able
to be in all of those wonderful places
and the only thing I could feel was
scared and
um and I don't know I just living life a
little differently now and I'm enjoying
it and I'm so focused and connected to
my gratitude to be in a place that's
wonderful like the nights like this are
rare and they should be enjoyed it's the
anisance baby it's the Renaissance and
just really quick happy early birthday
you've got a milestone birthday coming
up I would love to know what is one
personal and one professional goal you
have for yourself as you step into this
next decade
um
my personal goal is to Surf more
and my my professional goal is to
surprise myself
the surfing going I mean I'm not doing
it now so clearly not well
[Music]